respect du pixel syspro il est l'heure
de donner mon retour sur ce nouveau
smartphone de google alors petit récap
très léger souvenez vous
il ya quelques jours je vous présentais
le pixel 6 promet google a également
présenté le pixel 6 l'idée du pixel six
pros c'est le flagship
899 euros c'est la première fois que
google vous propose deux smartphones de
smartphones avec autant de choses et
surtout un smartphone positionné très
haut de gamme pour se mettre face à tout
le monde alors globalement on se disait
que google proposait des smartphones
pour mettre en avant sa technologie sa
partie software sauf que là il montre
vraiment les dents côté matériel on
appellera le hardware avec notamment ce
pixel six pros explique celle-ci ce
projet intéresse parce que déjà je
trouve assez joli alors vous remarquez
tout de suite et je vous le dis
directement ce pixel six pros il a eu un
petit souci avec moi il est tombé d'où
l'intérêt de le protéger et justement
sur une vidéo qu'a réalisé en
partenariat des créneaux chine parce que
je vous en parle souvent et je vous le
dis souvent pensé à protéger votre
smartphone bien cousu corning gorilla
glass à l'arrière et à l'avant ici c'est
le cas et bien malgré tout on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'un petit shoot on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un accident et
là il est tombé dans la voiture sur le
côté hier sans grand risque était dans
ma poche comme il est très glissant
comme il est là et bien il a glissé il
est tombé sur le côté pile poil et je
m'en suis rendu compte après on penser
vraiment mais vraiment à venir protéger
vos smartphones cette vidéo qui réalise
en partenariat des cris nauche il pensé
à venir protéger ici votre smartphone
mettez une coque à l'arrière je vous le
dis je vous le redis je vous le redis ça
évite franchement les déconvenues vous
prenez votre coque de rhinau schild qui
est très sympa alors vous avez soit une
coque comme ça un petit peu standard
soit encore vous avez dû choisir et de
chine ce ne sont pas des coques pour
être plus que celle-ci sopo de pixels 6
promet en tout cas vous pourrez avoir
les mêmes design ça c'est vachement bien
dans l'univers de dragon ball z masse l
âge là d'être vraiment hyper hyper hyper
canon vous en avez dans tous les univers
dans tous les styles league of legends
rick est morte y en a pour tout le monde
et si vous souhaitez voir également
votre dos avec vous voulez quand même le
protéger eh bien vous avez des bunkers
pourrait venir personnaliser la couleur
des boutons le contour bref c'est
vachement bien et en plus ils sont
changés d'emballage vous avez des
emballages éco responsable est-ce que ça
c'est pas hyper canon oui un petit peu
bravo et profiter de - 5% de remise avec
le code dreux qui affiche est juste là
en bas en dessous vous cliquez sur le
lien en bas dans la description ça vous
protégez vos smartphones dans les
meilleures conditions et ça c'est très
très cool ce smartphone j'aime bien il
est très atypique il est très
particulier on aimera ou on aimera pas
ça il n'y a pas de discussion à voir
d'ailleurs dit moi vous est-ce que vous
et ce design ce que vous voulez mais pas
du tout est ce que vous aimez cette
espèce de symétrie avec ce gros module
photo mes yeux c'est intéressant parce
que pour le coup google a vraiment
cherché comme on dit destructif changé
est différente pas faire comme les
autres donc ça j'aime beaucoup le seul
truc osseux commence à leur projet c'est
que je trouve très très grand mais il
faut dire qu'après on a une très jolie
dalle sauf que google a super bien aussi
sur cet écran ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est ses bords arrondis qui
apporte de l'immersion c'est très
agréable lorsque vous allez venir
naviguer ce crowley sur vos différents
réseaux sociaux tout ce que vous allez
bien faire ici avec et ben c'est quand
même vachement que le nôtre qui me
perturbe légèrement c'est ses boutons on
a le bouton de volume qui est juste en
dessous et on a le bouton on off qui est
là j'aurais préféré avoir le bouton de
volume lie bouton on off je ne sais pas
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai eu un
smartphone comme ça et du coup ça me
perturbe c'est très probable pour
revenir à cet écran pour venir regarder
des films des séries c'est vachement
bien j'adore ce côté très très immersif
mais sa tente beaucoup beaucoup de
profondeur et j'aime beaucoup plus salée
si je la trouve très lumineuse lorsque
vous allez en extérieur et qu'il fait
jour pas de souci si ça sera une très
très très agréable alors vous mettez pas
en corée soleil en plein mois de juillet
ça le fera pas mais sinon dans
l'ensemble c'est plutôt bien on a tous
rafraîchissement qui va de 10 à 100 en
mars alors qu'est ce que ça va nous
apporter ça ça vient vraiment nous
apporter sur l'expérience de fluidité
c'est vachement agréable alors ça on le
voit également sur le game et on va
parler de la plus dans quelques instants
la nouvelle puce google thème sens que
c'est vraiment aussi un point
extrêmement mais extrêmement si ce n'est
le point le plus intéressant est très
différent sur par rapport à tous les
smartphones du marché parce que c'est la
première fois que google sort une puce
maison avant travail avec qualcomm
aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'à on est
directement sur une puce google et c'est
super mais super intéressant regardez
pour venir jouer à des jeux type
asphalte neuf ici c'est vrai que c'est
quand même super super coûte écran de
bonne qualité bien calibré je trouve
vraiment efficace et un seul truc au
genou il reproché ici à cet écran c'est
un vrai petit miroir regardez là c'est
un petit peu sombre je vous ai tous
poussés à fond et je ne vois bien en
face à un vrai petit miroir donc ça
c'est ça peut paraître du point de
détail mais foyer samsam transcende pas
alors après l'expérience audio les haut
parleurs fonctionne bien haut parleurs
principal petit haut parleur enfants sur
le côté rien à dire particulier de ce
côté là ce smartphone maintenant ils
invoquent assez intéressant c'est que je
le trouve vachement grand et assez
mastoc si vous le comparez par rapport à
un iphone 13 promax on se parle je
décide un des plus gros smartphone qui
existe eh bien il est un peu plus grand
que l'iphone 13 pro mac ça peut paraître
du point de détail comme ça mais c'est
vrai que quand on se prend un
référentiel comme celui là et bien là
quand même tout de suite voix et c'est
pas rien ce qu'on peut aussi venir
reprocher c'est qu'il google a fait le
choix de ne proposer que dans une seule
couleur j'aurais aimé qu'on est plein de
couleurs en france non on a une seule
couleur alors après on sait très bien et
ça j'en parle avec tous les
constructeurs lorsqu un smartphone qui
sort les gens le prennent souvent en
noir quelque chose de très neutre donc
est ce que google se dit ok on est à
deux références on va y aller mollo au
niveau de la production en france on
verra ce qui se passera pour l'instant
on va le proposer en noir et qu'en noir
d'ailleurs je suis un noir ou un petit
rien le top pour est une petite couleur
top de toute façon je vous dis une fois
de plus vous le dis je vous le redis
mais tu es ici une coque de protection
de votre dos vous le verrez pas ce qui
n'est pas très glam si on puisse qu'on
se parle de google on se parle
d'expérience logiciel ici on tourne sur
une version d'android 12 qui est
complètement optimisé pour un pixel
syspro vous avez matériel ue pourrait
venir ajouter des widgets peuvent venir
customiser vos widgets garder on peut
changer les chiffres les formes des cils
et ça on peut venir totalement adapté la
couleur changer la déco bref y'a plein
de choses très sympas en termes de
personnalisation ici sur ce smartphone
vous allez dans fond d'écran est-il pour
échanger votre fond d'écran vous avez le
choix il y en a pas mal il ya des motifs
y en a plein de toutes les couleurs dont
vous pouvez vraiment bien trouver tout
ce que vous voulez ici vous avez aussi
des couleurs de base vous venez
customisée en fonction des couleurs
comme vous le souhaitez couleur du fond
je préfère et c'est vraiment l'idée ici
de matériel et/ou un c'est d'optimiser
tout l'affichage en fonction de la
couleur du moment dans ce poème est sur
le thème sombre bon ça c'est très très
grand classique j'aime bien c'est très
élégant et après les icônes à table
soient vos icônes elles sont comme ça un
petit peu standard soit vous choisissez
les icônes à thème c'est une version
bêta encore en fait sur les icônes du
thème et ça donne un côté un peu plus
sympa encore plus immersif et on est
vraiment dans grid appli aussi ça c'est
sympa soit vous mettez du très très gros
si vous voyez pas grand chose vous
voulez vendre juste et efficace soit
vous mettez une grille de 5 par 5 vont
là vous en êtes un paquet globalement ça
va piquer un peu les yeux - quatre par 5
ça me va très bien comme s'est
positionné ici quelques petits points
virin connaître ici notamment au niveau
de l'écran vous allez avoir les
différents types de couleur allant
réussissez adaptatif c'est ce que vous
avez par défaut mais vous pouvez le
mettre en naturel si vous les trucs très
flat réhaussé ça va rajouter un peu plus
de saturation et adaptatives là vous
venez pousser à fond c'est très punchy
l'affichage fluide en fait vous activez
le taux de rafraîchissement qui va venir
bouger entre 60 à 120 hertz et le dr
vous l'aurez lorsque vous serez sur le
all ways and display et si vous mettez
une protection d'écran et notamment est
mon partenaire et nos fils pense à
cliquer sur améliorer la sensibilité
tactile est aussi un autre point qui est
assez sympa c'est le côté sécurité que
vous retrouvez ici vous allez avoir une
vue d'ensemble sur la sécurité de votre
compte c'est la sécurité de votre
smartphone et ce également la sécurité
de votre compte google parce qu'il
oublie ici on est chez google et google
fait du google et c'est ce qu'on va
retrouver tout son utilisation donc le
déverrouillage par emprunt propose ici
un petit check up de la sécurité de mon
compte que chose à voir les mises à jour
bref j'ai tout ici sous les yeux on
aussi une partie sur la localisation
pour savoir quelle application va
utiliser votre position alors vous
pouvez soit le désactiver de façon
globale soit venir à l'activé
application par application et voir
cesser autorisé tout le temps où
toujours demandé bref c'est très clair
et c'est ça qui est intéressant autant
il ya pas 900 que vous déjà retrouvé
dans d'autres smartphones mais ici je
trouve ça très clair très lisible et
l'expérience est très agréable toute une
partie sur le bien-être numérique qui
n'est pas nouveau et qu'on trouvait déjà
ici avant que google vous voyez ce que
vous avez utilisé aujourd'hui notamment
et puis ce qui est très cool ici c'est
toute cette partie là qu'on a déjà vu
quand est présenté avec android 12 où je
trouve que l'expérience est assez
lisible sa syntaxe pouvait venir activer
désactiver tout ce que vous voulez
localisation activer/désactiver bref il
ya beaucoup de possibilités le thème
sombre en l'activant le désactive du
bout des doigts lorsque j'appuie entre
moment j'appuie moment s'activent il ya
une petite seconde
il vraiment une petite seconde en avoir
vraiment lent pourrait dire tiens on a
un nouvelle puce google tel sort et ça
devrait aller hyper vite ils nous
annoncent parfois qui va beaucoup plus
vite que le pixel 5 et pourtant lorsque
j'avais puis voyez j'ai ma petite
seconde comment ça se fait ça qui est
super intéressant que cette puce
mountain sort c'est que google n'a pas
créé une puce pour aller beaucoup plus
vite et pour faire beaucoup mieux
qualcomm ils ont créé une puce pour
optimiser leur smartphone du point de
vue de l'intelligence artificielle du
point de vue du machine learning du
point de vue de google en fait google
fait du google essaie une fois de plus
l'idée globale ici dans ce smartphone
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
pas trouver que c'est le smartphone le
plus performant et y'a qu'à regarder les
benchmark qu'on va retrouver ici dans
tout ou si je retrouve avec un score
total de 543 1928 autant vous dire que
par rapport à tous les autres du marché
et les ceux qui sont vraiment dans le
haut du panier mais il est aux fraises
de tout premier que j'ai ici qui en tête
de lice et nubia raid magic six pros et
si je vais chercher mon pixel et bien il
est quand même relativement bas dans la
liste très très bas dans la librairie et
en 52e position il se trouve après un
galaxy à 9,10 plus venir méfier ici un
petit peu du test logiciel fait part en
tout je prendre avec des pincettes c'est
vrai que je m'attendrais à voir quelque
chose beaucoup plus qu'à forme en avoir
il pu totalement optimisé alors je la
trouve pas extrêmement optimisé si en
terme de performance mais je trouve
extrêmement optimisé pour tout ce qui va
être traitement des photos et une fois
de plus google va faire du google sfr du
google je vous montre une photo ici moi
et elliott regardez on est là lorsque
vous venez faire une photo et bien
souvent il ya des gens en arrière-plan
et vous avez envie de les éliminer alors
pas de les éliminer mais en tout cas de
les effacer de votre photo bien pour y
faire très facilement vous allez d'en
modifier hockey d'ailleurs il vous le
suggérez sais pas si vous avez vu est
fasciné par son arrière plan je vous
montrer comment on fait réellement vous
avez d'en modifier vous allez dans hop
là d'un outil et vous avez dans gomme
magique donc là vous avez votre gomme
magique ça vient a analysé la photo ça
vous faire une suggestion donc là c'est
assez simple il m'a mis elliott en
surbrillance la voyez il voit en fait
aux idées et ensuite je vais cliquez ici
sur toutes effacées ou hockey et c'est
hyper impressionnant parce que y'a plus
rien autre point qui est très révélateur
est super intéressant j'ai fait des
photos à contre-jour alors qu'est ce qui
se passe ici voyez normalement lorsque
vous avez le soleil derrière sur un
chemin en forêt eh bien on y va
globalement rien eh ben si vous voulez
regarder vous vous désolez sur moi il a
réussi quand même à le récupérer mon
visage on me voit on voit bien tous
contours il arrive vraiment à détacher
et là on le voit regarder tout le
contour autour de moi alors je veux bien
quel soleil derrière qu'ils fassent
ressortir on voit que c'est là qu'il
était hyper pushy d'un point de vue
algorithmique les oreilles sont rouges
le visage ressort et pourtant je suis
complètement à contre jour et c'est un
petit peu ce que venir reproché ici aux
photos de google pourquoi parce que si
vous voulez un smartphone automatique
intelligent vous appuyez il fait une
photo et vous fera le maximum quelle que
soit la configuration du lieu de la
lumière est bien lui fera le maximum il
le fera il le fera très bien mais on est
loin d'une photo on est loin du naturel
on est loin de la réalité ça ça n'existe
pas si vous faites de la photo sur un
contre jour ici je devrais être noir
uniquement noir donc si vous voulez
vraiment joué sur les ondes et venir
travailler sur un vrai contre jours
c'est un petit peu compliqué si vous
voulez vraiment le faire alors on peut
le faire vous venez vous mettre là vous
appuyez et là vous pouvez venir moduler
la luminosité module également la
température des couleurs donc on peut
venir rattraper un peu ici mais c'est
vrai que dans l'idée du smartphone
poitan shoot et bien lui il est pratique
mais il fait les boutons qui sont assez
fake parce qu'il va chercher à ce que
vous voyez tout à la différence et c'est
ce que je reprochais souvent que c'est
très drôle en fait à sony avec ses
expériences à l'extérieur 5 c'est que on
est pas paul ten shoot on va aller
chercher dans les paramètres ça est un
peu plus complexe vous avez un peu les
deux extraits missiles d'un côté google
avec un smartphone qui va tout gérer
automatiquement vous appuyer la photo
tout ressort ont des lois de l'univers
de la photographie et si vous voulez
dans l'univers la photographie a
contrario vous prenez un ex-paria one ou
un xperia 5 lui vous êtes vraiment dans
l'idée du photographe qui va venir
chercher des choses telles qu on
trouverait avec un appareil photo
classique il ya des effets de flou aussi
qui existent aujourd'hui la vraie photo
c'est ça je suis en train de marcher et
lui comme on l'en du déplacement il me
créer une idée de mouvement alors je
trouve ça assez rigolo pourquoi pas on
suit une personne on ya du mouvement ne
s'est pas hyper évident à a chuté ils
ont un autre qu'ils ont créé j'ai un
cours d'eau la vraie photo c'est ça
c'est ma petite rivière et lorsque
j'active ça eh bien voyez hop on
ressente dans une cascade avec un grand
mouvement c'est de la pause longue en
fait sauf que cette pause langue elle
peut être rigolo comme ça mais il ya un
moment où c'est un peu fait qu voyez
typiquement la trouve que c'est hyper
fake et ça marche pas donc ça peut être
rigolo dans certaines configurations
mais dans l'ensemble c'est pas non plus
complètement saoul faut donc c'est plein
de petites nouveautés c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que google fait du
google et google c'est faire du google -
des photos que j'ai prises avec mon
google pixels six pros alors là c'était
un petit essai pour essayer de voir un
petit reflets de lumière bon ok pourquoi
pas une petite photo prise de côté là
c'est mon pote léo qui l'a prise et
c'est un peu poussif à pour venir faire
tout ressortir mais bon pourquoi pas on
voit quand même bien les grain de peau
et ça peut être assez impressionnant
avec un flou derrière les grains de
paula bon pourquoi pas je trouve un
petit peu froide s'arrête là où certains
smartphones notamment apple va
réchauffer un peu ses photos ici elles
sont un peu plus froide mais ça
fonctionne très très bien en place et le
grand-angle non pas sur lui travaux
entend très bien pas particulièrement
déformant dans l'ensemble ça marche
plutôt très bien au niveau de la photo
on vient se rapprocher x 210 x 4 on va
jusqu'au x 20 alors fois avant une fois
de plus voyez bien un petit peu lisse et
tout ça mais le taf est pas mauvais là
on est sûr en x 10 intermédiaire donc
pour venir shooter avec le téléobjectif
l' ultra grand-angle est grand temps que
ça fonctionne bien là c'est pareil à des
photos à ce que j'ai vraiment tenir
leurs projets tout au long et vous allez
voir là il a le soleil en pleine phase
il n'a pas aimé tout salarié sur le côté
c'est pas terrible et on va le retrouver
à plusieurs endroits regardez-la trois
photos de différentes et on l'a on a
encore plein de fac donc ça c'est des
points où il a un petit peu de mal
et lorsque vous n'avez pas ce soleil là
vous n'avez pas ce problème là et bien
c'est quand même plutôt bien scellé
google donc c'est sûr saturé il viens
vous apporter une expérience google pour
maximiser pour embellir vos photos au
maximum alors si vous aimez pas le côté
un peu sursaturé tel que vous l'avez là
c'est peut-être pas fait pour vous mais
on va reconnaître que c'est quand même
relativement efficace là c'est pareil on
le voit ici un petit détail là c'est pas
un arc-en-ciel anti reflets là sont la
lumière les hautes lumières là j'ai
l'impression que au niveau de la
compensation elle a eu un petit peu de
mal au niveau des nuages regardez on
peut venir jouer se rapprocher on voit
ici les parapentes dans le ciel donc ça
marche quand même pas trop trop mal et
la radio c'est quand même vachement
rapprocher alors on voit un qui a eu un
gros traitement logiciel ici au niveau
des arbres pour que ça fonctionne bien
mais malgré tout
le taf est fait et il est vraiment bien
fait ici la caméra cette fille donnant
rendu qu relativement honnête pareil
grosse expo ici est vraiment je devrais
très sombre c'est tout le côté logiciel
tout le côté algorithmique de google
poussée avec cette puce google tensor
qui fait le taff et qu'il le fait plutôt
bien mais il ya un côté un peu pas
naturel parce que lorsque j'ai le soleil
comme ça normalement sur une vraie photo
je dois être sombre je me sens comme un
petit peu plus en noir et blanc ici et
ça vient vraiment contrasté avec tout le
côté saturé ici regardez là c'est très
saturé la la salle est un petit peu
moins à cause du soleil le visage les
beaucoup de moins mais malgré tout le
taf effet l'un est son grand angle en
laissons-le ultra-grand-angle c'est pas
parfait mais ça reste quand même
bluffant c'est du google lagarde et je
suis en mouvement hop plus de mouvements
je suis pas hyper hyper fan de cet effet
il est rigolo maintenant est ce qu les
dingos d'un mot je pense pas peut-être
trouvé vraiment la bonne scène qui fait
que ça marchera voyons ce que je suis à
contre jour on voit bien tout le
détourage qui est fait ici de tous les
côtés ça veut dire qu'en fait ce qu'il a
fait c'est pas qui m'a pas des tours et
c'est que si c'est toute la lumière qui
vient du soleil et lui il a fait le taf
pour tout faire ressortir ici et vous
puissiez tout lire alors une fois depuis
son nez ce petit bazar ouvriers ici
qu'on retrouve un peu à droite à gauche
les photos avec la pause longue sur les
liquides ça marche mais bon je suis pas
hyper hyper hyper fan - le mode portrait
je trouve pas dingue dingue et c'est là
où on dit c'est dommage parce que c'est
google qui ne sort une puce google
regarder entre mes doigts j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est des
processeurs milieu de gamme qui me font
ça et là que le global - sinon n'est pas
sur un processeur milieu de gamme on est
vraiment optimisé pour la photo sur le
détourage ça me paraît pas dingue dingue
ou alors se complique avec mes cheveux
par contre un la veille c'est un petit
peu floue dans cette zone là alors ça
devrait pas l'être c'est pas parfait en
très très loin d'être parfait là dessus
donc il ya encore des choses à venir
améliorer google hélas et des photos
qu'on souhaite il ya pas beaucoup de
lumière c'est assez froid c'est très
bleu le traitement qu'on va me retrouver
ici voyez alors qu'on est dans les mêmes
conditions où il ya du soleil et sur la
photo de nu c'est sensiblement la même
chose tout ça assez froid on va avoir
tout ce bazar il va du mal à gérer les
lumières vous allez voir un globalement
bien retrouver un peu partout ça c'est
sur l'ultra grand tante dont je lui
pardonnerai plus ultra grand-angle la
nuit le grand-angle l'ultra grand temps
que la nuit s'est pas ouf regardez la
lumière lampadaires c'est pas normal
qu'on ait ce bazar on doit avoir une
scène beaucoup plus optimisé mais les
hautes lumières la la nuit en tout cas
et même la journée il a du mal pareil
ici il a du mal c'est dommage que le
reste est vraiment pas mal du tout
l'ultra grand temps les plus durs une
fois de plus lui en veux pas regardez là
c'est pareil ça me pourrit ma photo
toute la partie droite est sympa et la
lumière paf sa part à vau l'eau là c'est
pareil on le voit un petit peu ici alors
là il est vraiment poussif et il vient
nous faire ressortir les étoiles dans
tout ça c'est joli mais il faut pas qu
et ses lumières en deux villes parce que
il a du mal à gérer ça c'est dommage
donc je pense qu'on a encore un peu de
boulot avec le machine learning derrière
donc une fois que vous avez trouvé la
cei qui est pas mal c'est pas trop
pollué par les éclairages et m'a regardé
c'est pas mal quand même est-ce que ça
vous sort ici ça c'est bluffant là aussi
c'est assez joli on voit qui est lumière
dans le coin ça ressort un peu mais
c'est pas mal donc si vous êtes comme
moi en utilisant un ou deux contres
voire trois comptes google si vous avez
comme chez moi une google laisse d'or la
nouvelle sonnette connecter via c'est
intéressant parce que dès qu'on va venir
sonner chez vous ça va s'afficher ici
vous allez pouvoir venir répondre à
distance comme ça c'est super
intéressant si vous aimez l'expérience
photo google si vous utilisez nouvelles
photos si vous avez du stockage dans le
cloud google et si vous êtes 100% google
ça c'est un super smartphone hyper
optimisé pour du google si maintenant
vous aimez vraiment la photographier que
vous voulez vraiment vous amuser avec
des jeux d'ombré de lumière c'est
peut-être pas celui qu'il nous faudra
parce que il va être un peu trop
automatique mais je peux pas leur
reprocher le boulot qui fait parce que
il le fait bien on va tout la puissance
de cette nouvelle puce google tensor
vous avez ici avec de lia avec du
machine learning donc si on résume pour
me regarder des films des séries ça
fonctionnera attention sur des films et
des séries un petit peu son parce que
vous allez avoir quand même pas mal de
reflets et ça c'est pas dingue dingue
pour la productivité aussi on a un très
grand écran donc ça va être assez
agréable si vous avez un google shit un
google docs sur lequel vous voulez venir
travailler facilement pour tout ce qui
va être gaming ça fonctionnera bien mais
si on veut le max de performance on voit
pour l'instant tout cas qu'il faut
rester chez qualcomm ici sur nos
smartphones android donc il ce que j'ai
vraiment aimé je trouve que google a
optimisé son hardware à chercher
vraiment à le maîtriser de a à z avec
cette nouvelle puce qui va dans l'idée
de google dans l'idée de l'intelligence
artificielle dans l'idée de vous
apporter google is it où google dans
votre smartphone que vous soyez connecté
en ligne ou hors ligne parce que oui
hors ligne il faut aussi beaucoup de
choses grâce à cette puce made in google
là où une plus de qualcomm ne pouvait
pas aller aussi loin pour faire du
google et bien eux ils font des google
grâce à leur puce et c'est extrêmement
optimisé donc là smartphone qui peut
être super intéressant pour plaint d'
usage mais qui malgré tout aujourd'hui
en tout cas garde quand même quelques
petites limites même si je le trouve
intéressant a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire c'est un bon smartphone et
sa très bon smartphone si vous aimez
google si vous êtes 100% google je
dirais aujourd'hui sas intéressante
qu'on peut venir femmes parallèle si
vous n'êtes pas fan d'apple eh bien vous
avez tous les produits 100 % apple avec
des puces apple avec une expérience
apple avec une expérience logiciels et
matériels apple et c'est la même chose
ici aujourd'hui le vrai parallèle se
situe ici au niveau de votre pixels six
pros et pixel si ce matériel google+
google optimisation google pour faire du
google donc si vous aimez google et que
vous êtes un google a dicté pixels ci
sous pixel syspro ici a vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous êtes un
google a dit est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser parce que c'est vraiment le
smartphone qu'il vous faut si vous êtes
un google a dit si c'était le cas passez
votre chemin vous embrasse à bientôt des
bisous ciao
[Musique]